joe biden está haciendo todo lo posible
para ayudar a crear y a defenderse de la
ofensiva rusa el jueves el presidente
estadounidense pidió al congreso ayuda
adicional por 33 mil millones de dólares
que equivale a 31.400 millones de euros
el costo de esta lucha no es barata pero
ceder a la agresión va a ser más costoso
si lo permitimos o apoyamos al pueblo
ucraniano en la defensa de su país o nos
quedamos quietos y dejamos que los rusos
continúen con sus atrocidades y
agresiones
el último paquete incluye más de 19 mil
millones de euros en ayuda militar 8 mil
millones de euros en ayuda económica y
3.000 millones de euros en ayuda
humanitaria y alimentaria sumas que han
permitido a eeuu hacer valer su
influencia como la principal nación que
apoya quiere sin duda que este es un
importante paso por parte de los eeuu
estoy muy agradecido con los ciudadanos
americanos y particularmente con el
presidente de bailén y espero que el
congreso apruebe este pedido y ayude a
mi nación una verdad desde el comienzo
de la invasión rusa washington ha
proporcionado ya más de 7.600 millones
de euros en ayuda a ucrania mientras
francia ocupa el quinto lugar en cuanto
a contribuciones con 416 millones de
euros mientras tanto la ayuda total
europea de los estados miembros e
instituciones asciende a 6 mil 900
millones de euros por su parte eeuu se
prepara para una larga guerra con su
nueva ampliación presupuestaria la casa
blanca pretende por tanto obtener fondos
suficientes para apoyar la resistencia
ucraniana hasta octubre pero el proyecto
de ley podría tropezar con el congreso
por desacuerdos entre demócratas y
republicanos
el partido demócrata quiere incluir en
el presupuesto un aumento destinado a
hacer frente al cob y 19 una medida que
los republicanos rechazan